so one of the best bits of Arkham
origins was the forensic scanner in
which you could piece together a bit of
a crime scene to make the overall
picture and I'm really glad that
Rocksteady decided to adapt it saying as
WB Montreal stole so much from their
games it's it's really just a nice way
of sort of seeing how Batman would look
at a crime scene forensic ly and figure
out exactly what had happened you can
sort of see shades of this within the
Dark Knight although it's not exactly
you know bang on but the way that he
uses the the sonar and the the great
detective scene in the in the Dark
Knight where he looks at the bullets
Kansa and works out which gun it's from
and then from there can piece together
the fingerprints and one after reader
speak volumes to how like good of a
detective Batman is and why so far
advanced beyond the police because he
has got all this great technology that
allows them to piece together bits
similar to the long Halloween which is
very much a detective story it's nice
that they're they remember the Dark
Knight's roots obviously came from
Detective Comics Detective Comics 27
1939 written by Bill Finger and Bob Kane
and it's great that they've they played
into those roots because know they got
the guy's a bloody great guy I don't
know what I wasn't meant to be doing
yeah because I was talking but you know
it's nice but hair this has all been a
part of it and one of the best detective
of the vehicle comics I actually think
is a single-issue it's part of futures
end from Detective Comics I believe and
it centers around Batman and taking the
Riddler into Arkham to sort of break
everything at down if you're sort of
more of the cerebral side of Batman out
definitely recommend anything with the
Riddler in I like this game you know
where he just leaves trophies about and
sets up racehorses you know which stuff
to the job The Riddler would never do a
lot of them are very you know cerebral
and psychological especially ones like
the caliber of the weapon is zero yeah
this is part 1 of 0 as secret city which
sort of introduces the Riddler but he's
not the main villain of that it actually
centers around the Red Hood gang which
is Titan the origin of the Joker but the
second part of it Dark City is when the
the Riddler's taken over Gotham it's in
no-man's land
and he challenges that every like
citizens everyday a riddles and if they
and so on right you'll set the city free
I know once managed to do it though so
yeah definitely recommend picking those
up there are unfortunately some stories
like dog victory which I mentioned
earlier in which the the riddle as a
complete buffoon but yeah there's a nice
one there's also Catwoman when in Rome
which the the Riddler paid plays a big
part of but he just comes across like an
absolute idiot and it's sort of yeah
it's not doesn't it's not really fair to
the characters routes because there are
brilliant stories in which he is the
Dark Knight sequel on so many levels
sorry burly
so no matter how many times that happens
I always completely crap me pants I
should know by now but whenever I say it
I was the director we'll talk about is
leather on leather wings which was the
first animated series Batman episode and
the animated series obviously has a huge
influence on this game saying is that it
was the first time that Mark Hamill
Kevin Conroy were cast in the roles of
Batman and the Joker and it's it's
really I think it's an absolutely
outstanding episode up so you know a lot
of criticisms mainly coming from IGN
saying that they didn't like it but I
think it's absolutely brilliant like
everything down at the animations
top-notch it's the first time that the
orchestra gets introduced and it really
cements the the the world and set up a
lot of the aesthetics of this universe
like there's a brilliant bit where
Batman's down in the Batcave and a
doctor comes on and he just you can see
just him switching in the Bruce Wayne
persona like the doctor calls him and he
just switches right anyways like oh hey
what's up duck and then as soon as the
phone hangs up he's like those bets they
are not that way and it's really great
to see the transition between the two
and you can sort of view them as two
entities like one of the brilliant
things about Christopher Reeve Superman
was when he was Clark Kent the guy was a
bumbling idiot it was a complete buffoon
you just couldn't see him as Superman
yeah as soon as those glasses come up is
really backwards straight enough he
would you know he gained a backbone and
it really you could see the
transformation and almost view them as
two separate entities be and it was so
well put together and
that's mirrored in the way that Kevin
Conroy plays Batman and Bruce Wayne it's
just a breathtaking episode and it's
it's got all of the heights of Gotham it
introduces the blimps and it's about
Batman stopping man but and it's sort of
a it has horror elements to it you see
the transformation between the dr.
Langstrom and his alter-ego man-bat it's
just really like atmospheric and I
definitely recommend you you watch it if
you haven't seen it in a while it still
holds up today it's on Amazon Prime or
you can buy the DVD collection
definitely recommend picking up Batman
bats re is one of my favorite Batman
characters of the animated series and
it's it's great to see him reappear in
this game and over there you can see the
good ol Arkham City I don't think that's
a riddle to be honest and you've got the
Wonder tower there which is obviously
where Batman had his final confrontation
with Hugo Strange brilliant game and
watch my playthrough of the first couple
of hours if you get a chance to it's not
as good as this one year I wasn't as up
on the editing yet so it just kind of
Rahman but yeah definitely check it out
and get the game get the remaster
version of it because it still holds up
today is one of the best about my games
of all time and you get autumn Asylum
along with it so take it one of the best
parts of this game is definitely this
moment I think when you sort of just
viewing exactly visiting the underground
and seeing all of the ways that Arkham
Knight has been planning this out with
scarecrow and you know it's you sort of
becoming aware slowly of how much he
hates you I love how the Joker's just
sort of starting over them now when
you're still getting flashbacks of them
this bit though don't really and this
and he was I've scanned that area before
all that wasn't up there and also it
comes around the side and shoots you
hidden like the intestines um in Batman
like he just sprays the thing and that's
it you never it never needs to deal with
it again it would be great if you kept
having moments where Batman was like you
know about attack someone and then he
realizes like he's in so much pain
because he's been shot on the side no
lad he never takes the bullet out so I
don't know exactly how how he's still
walking around with a big piece of lead
inside him yeah a nice little touch nice
guys I know it's a comic book yeah I
know it's not real yeah none of this is
real but they just I just expected
better realism in the place up what the
hell and so it's great how you you stuck
in this zone until you realized that
you've got your bloody best mate with
you all the time
I know sometimes the Batmobiles a bit of
a hindrance especially when you fighting
700 waves of drones which I've read it
over 200 by mine comics and a Korra
member that happened in the comic violet
I'm taking a bit a creative license on
it and but just moments like this it's
absolutely great the fact that I just
get you out of everything and you know
it it is nice to have it there when we
were playing Arkham Asylum and Arkham
City back in the day we were moaning on
all the time going
I wish the Batmobiles here and roxelle
you were like well you want your
Batmobile you can have it you can have
it every single moment of the day yeah I
think I remember them saying that at e3
when they were pitching the game so it
is good that it's popped up a lot of
Batman stories feature the Batmobile but
there's not really a Batmobile centric
storyline which is a bit strange
however in Batman v 1 volume 2 did they
they sort of they talk about how Batman
you know he's obviously got a team who
builds all this stuff there's no way one
man could sit and build like all the
Batcave and all the gadgets he has and
so they sort of a sign Lucius Fox's
staff at Wayne Enterprise to work on
stuff and just say it's like it's for
millionaires like they just like oh yeah
Batman ones this is not just what we
gave the game away sorry I mean Bruce
Wayne your boss he wants a car built and
that sort of can thrive on water and fly
so yeah make sure you get that done and
then just as the lads are finishing it
up to draw suspicion away they're like
oh he's changed his mind he doesn't want
it anymore I don't know if you've ever
worked for a millionaire before but I
have I'm a web designer and my full-time
job and there it's great because you've
got a constant flow of work because you
know it's a guy with a lot of money but
they also changed their mind at like
anyone's business so that's sort of is
what comes across from Bruce Wayne's
betrayal you say I want a pair of boots
that allows you to walk on the walls of
Gotham's sewer system and then IRA will
build that and
Lucius we've done it will built them
will build them it took seven months but
we're finding it
oh yeah Bruce has changed his mind he
didn't want that anymore he actually
wants a grapple garden of that also
shoots of daisies in LA right there well
Batman wouldn't want that but so he's
definitely not Batman and I'm sick of me
life but we'll build it he's like I know
use a sickening like because you keep
getting this work giving to you and then
taking off but um yeah actually the lads
decided because you've been such a good
stuff he's gonna give you a little pay
rise and I like alright well we'll do it
so that's sort of an insight of what
it's like working for someone rich and
it also explains how Batman gets the
Batmobile bill he gets all these gadgets
play and he operates without people
really getting too suspicious because if
you knew your boss was Batman though he
was paying you a crapload of money all
the time he'd be like I might just might
just let the lad keep doing it it's bit
a bit of a funny bit because he drives
drives the bloody thing when he said I
love how that God thou had a arkham like
voice modulator though you can also get
them for batman in ASDA I seen one
yesterday the little helmet you put on
and you sound like Batman from the movie
Batman V Superman so one for the kids I
mean for your twenty nine-year-old
brother which might just be me so make
sure you get as one for Christmas that's
just a message to my sister because I
know I know shorten seas
but yeah I don't know if it was very
Batman drivings you know the Batmobile
with a buddy 6900 inch tire don't know
if that's the size that I realize
halfway through that sentence I'm not
very sure that the size of these tires
but yeah woody necessarily do that on a
large head probably not he would
probably do what he does in the Dark
Knight Returns which is take out a guy's
body up to a roof and just hang him over
the edge
oh hey I just sort of had a riddle
like involving the fact that you have no
hand that's kind of why I was like
looking over your shoulder scanning you
it's not because I'm weird or anything
it's actually like got called the riddle
I sort of yeah he's been making fun of
your hand we've all kind of noticed I
know you made it
I made a hook clear away yeah we all
know so this is one of the DLC add-ons
involving the Mad Hatter which I kind of
want to talk about because the Mad
Hatter right yeah absolutely hate him as
a villain it's I just think it's
ridiculous that they even made the Mad
Hatter into a Batman Bell it's like it's
like picking up you know a Yukon thing
of a villain I'm trying to write a comic
I can't think of a bill oh what's this
book in the library
Alice in Wonderland right just just pick
a character out of that put them in
Batman the comic got a deadline on
Monday we need it in so I've never
really liked it the guy always sort of
his storylines always evolve revolve
around him kidnapping a blonde haired
woman dressed neuromas Alice from Alice
in Wonderland
sometimes she has a boyfriend that he
beats up
maybe she just but a man has to stop the
mud how we're his soldiers up dressed
like rabbits and his hats that he put
some people's head they make them
hypnotized by a mind control is another
thing that I always hate absolutely hate
mind control because it's such a crap
part of a story but anyway I digress
the reason I'm recording it is not to
slag the light off Scott Snyder has
completely changed my mind on the
character and like I said I didn't
really like he liked the guy at all not
Scott Snyder all of that guy matter but
in all-star Batman in Rob it's also a
Batman not also Batman and Robin which
it's terrible and also Batman Scott
Snyder has done a story called into the
earth in which Batman sort of travels
around trying to stop a virus on his way
he encounters Mad Hatter Mad Hatter's
like looking a little [ __ ] your you
know my hats yeah they they control
people's minds that make them see what
they want to see don't know if you
remember me but we actually met once
when you would just return to Gotham
you are part of Wayne enterprise and you
know you turned me down you didn't like
my idea he's like yes I remember that
anyway it turns out that the Mad Hatter
had developed a hawk that when you put
it on it allowed you the skin the world
as you saw fit similar a snapchat felt
as similar sort of VR you could use this
thing and it would pick up on your
fantasies and make you see the world in
the way you've seen it in the flashbacks
Batman's Bruce Wayne so he's been
wearing a bloody hat so um yes he's mad
hat is like look you you probably don't
remember what actually give you that hat
that you had correct wise it's not
working
I give me that hat and we get controlled
on this I'm very good it's sort of
ruining me moment in it explaining this
so you you don't remember but I gave you
that hat and you've actually what
happened was you wanted to be Batman but
you you paralyzed yourself and you've
been sat in a chair like a wheelchair
you can't move but you've got this hat
on that makes you think about your
Batman and he starts explaining how all
of Batman's enemies like the Joker and
Bane there are actually just people as
psychiatrists you know the doctors
trying to help and heal Bruce Wayne and
take him out of this world because the
Mad Hatter says unfortunately when I
developed the Hat I didn't realize how
addictive it would be and you refused to
take it off and accept the world as it
is in Batman to say and even as a reader
I was like bloody hell the last 75 years
of Batman history have been a lie he's
just a lad sat in a chair getting
hypnotized and it's been on snapchat too
long he's he's obsessed with all that
you want so this is an absolutely
brilliant story and spoilers coming up
clap man goes well if that is the case
and I am stuck in this virtual reality
world then it means that if I kill you
then nothing there's going to be no
consequences because you are not real
obviously the Mad Hatter it's like our
crowd who's gonna kill it he starts
beating the crap out of them and Mad
Hatter's like okay sorry concern here
lighting it you are you're real I'm
sorry but it's just a really nice twist
I and as I was breathing I was like wow
Scott Snyder has taken this goofy
character that I really didn't like and
he's managed to change him into
something that a massively respect
so definitely it's just come out as a
hardcover I definitely recommend that
you pick up all-star Batman both volume
1 and volume 2 because they're
absolutely outstanding haven't read much
of the the issues in the lead up to
volume 3 but you know it's Scott Snyder
it's gonna be great work so make sure
you go pick that up and interestingly
that story with the Mad Hatter ties in
to racial Ghul he's sort of developed
the virus you find out and he's
unleashing it on the city of course you
know Batman he's not too thick so but
you see Scott he's got this stuff
planned out but the only right door has
no power actually done this mission
before um yeah you see a scene where
racial ghoul shoots Batman in the head
he unleashes the virus and he kills the
entire world and he finally wins and
then you realize that tying back into a
little virus the little Mad Hatter I
think Donnie's head so he thinks he's
won so it's a really nice little finish
to the story it's a full arc issue and I
just think it's absolutely breathtaking
basically I 100% recommend that you pick
it up and get yourself away and here is
Rachel ghoul in his lovely lovely humble
abode
it's very fasting though and I
definitely recommend you check out birth
of the demon I think it is in which it
tells the origin story of racial Ghul he
basically started off as an advisor to
the salt
centuries ago the Sun was it was a bit
of a head um but you know he was his
advisor so he had a look after him
anyway the the Sultan got ill so the son
got ill from a virus and raesha
discovered and developed the Lazarus
pity to bring him back from the edge of
death unfortunately in the Lazarus Pit
there lies a certain madness and once
you are fully revived and you go mad for
a certain amount of time and the Sun Sun
come out and killed
Rachele girls wife and the somethings
father obviously been heavily biased
towards his son was fine outcast race
and then racial cool sort of had to to
delve into the relay service pit himself
and he goes from a good man to a bad man
and he uses the virus once more this is
when they sort of discover and micro
viruses and things like that and
obviously it was a time before science
it was a thousand years ago and he uses
this weapon to take out all of the
Sultan and his followers without even
raising a finger really and it really
shows the the methodical thinking of
racial Ghul and I definitely recommend
you to check that hours it's such a good
in interesting origin story and that
summarizes my third playthrough of
Arkham connect starring Batman I hope
you having a good time with it I'm I'm
really good time so recapping everything
and going through the graphic novels and
if you are having a great time I'd
really appreciate it if you can
subscribe to my channel I post things
like this all the time I've recently
done a video review of the Dark Knight
Returns where I'm analyzing an
issue-by-issue
and I definitely recommend that year you
just check it out if you like Batman and
stuff like me if you bit of a loser like
me then check it out or if you're a cool
guy check it out as well so thanks very
much for checking everything out and I
hope to see you next time
take care peace
you